you don't have to have a story you don't
have to have an idea just connect with
that moment and maybe you'll write crap
but you'll write
is that why you love writing poetry the
rhythm
of the writing the rhythm of the word
well the rhythm is the rhythm of the
voice
i mean that's the rhythm of the the deep
voice speaking to someone else in a very
intimate way
and
connecting with him you know
um
i i talked about um
my dog jessie who
um
she had cancer and we had to put her
down
um
it's in one of my books i i like
i like different sizes i like when i'm
doing a book i like to think what size
do i want it to be like lucky finds with
all the cards now most most of my books
are going to be
you know the normal size of a book but
once in a while i i'm curious so like i
did a book of haiku oh yeah and i wanted
it to be a flip book so i i thought it
would be about
that thick
and it would be 50 haiku but it ended up
i wrote 300 haiku and i wrote a
introduction
that was uh close to 450 pages oh so
it's got a 450 page introduction and
then it's got 301 haiku
and the introduction
is um
what does it say here it says
um
in 201 chapters and 601 paragraphs
so
the little book i was going to do ended
up being like that and
it kind of grew so i i i kind of like
different things
this book is a smaller book too
and um
it has a
i think of it as a circus
the poems are all different and i have a
chagall painting in the front and on the
back it's got a roomy quote with passion
prey with passion make love with passion
eat and drink and dance and play why
look like a dead fish in the ocean of
god
rumi
so i have a poem in here that is about
my dog
jesse this is not an earth-shattering
poem it's just about my dog jesse who
we had to put down
jesse my dog
i was driving back from a music recital
this evening
and found myself cruising down a street
i used to frequent 30 years ago
but haven't driven down since
so many of the places i used to go to
are gone
a favorite italian restaurant now a
fitness center
a bookstore now an antique store
a cafe where i read most of 100 years of
solitude now an ice cream parlor
it isn't as if i was planning to go to
any of those places but it makes me sad
to know they're gone it doesn't really
matter
i'm 72 years old
a lot is gone
it's all gonna go
eventually
by the cafe a boy was walking his dog
along the sidewalk
one day the boy will be gone along with
his dog
my dog is gone
jesse used to lie by my feet as i sat at
the computer trying to write a poem
she's gone now
no more jessie
after i'd written the poem i'd take
jessie out for her midnight walk
sometimes we'd pass a house and the
people inside might still be up sitting
at the table talking and drinking
but mostly the streets were quiet and
she and i would enjoy the night air
the way the leaves rustled when a wind
came up from the ocean
maybe a poem would be buried in
someone's front yard and jesse would dig
it up and bring it to me
like a bone she just found
that poem
about the man in charge of watering
jesse dug that one up she just dug it up
and brought it to me what you got there
girl
she dropped it on the sidewalk then
trotted off
looking for more poems more bones
no more bones now
and few poems to be dug up except this
one
which is torn at the edges and i've
stopped caring about the line breaks or
the metaphors or even the kind of things
a poet is supposed to do when writing a
poem making everything ship shape
no more bones no more ship shape
i'm not even sure you are reading this
poem right now maybe
no one is reading it like i said earlier
it doesn't matter you know i write the
poems anyway
jesse will come back some night
take my poems on our walk
and bury them in someone's front yard
and all i'll have to do in my remaining
years
is walk my weary bones down the sidewalk
and dig them up
dig up those poems that jesse buried
my good girl talk
taking such good care of me then and now
jesse won't be with me but i'll thank
her
give her a good rub on the back
then
i'll let her go
so that's about my dog jesse that's
beautiful
so
it's not so much rhythm as the voice
you know
sometimes there are rhythmic things you
can do and that's part of your technique
so it depends if i'm doing to be read
and sung
you know the repetition then i would do
that you know
it's also about
loss and change
you know you talked about walking down
the street and the this restaurant isn't
here anymore and this bookstore has
changed well it's about i'm 70 i wrote
that when i was 72 i'm 78 now so i wrote
that six years ago it's about
thinking
you know as i said my dad died when he
was 54 and i i wasn't i always
thought i would live longer than he did
so
you know when i wrote the poem i was 72
and
you know i'm
feeling older your bones your body you
don't
you know i can't dunk anymore
you know
i can't throw a football 70 yards uh and
so
you also think of what you can't do as
an artist that
you're getting older and
uh things are gonna be gone you're gonna
lose things friends will die and loved
ones will leave and
i was just thinking about that and
feeling all that
and that jessie was gone but
i thought of how she would bury my poems
and then dig them up which is a metaphor
of course
[Music]
and that eventually i'd pet her and let
her go that
at some point
the poems don't come anymore
and the muse that brings you the poems
whether it's your dog or the muse or
whatever
that will end too
and you have to
let it go you have to
give him a pet and
let it go
whether it's a poem or a lover
a loved one friend
whatever
what do you mean by the muse won't come
anymore
well the muse you know i don't i don't
believe in the muse but i'm just using
that cliche that you know poets sit and
write and the muse comes and gives you
the poem i don't believe that i believe
that you the muse is in you but i just
use that cliche as a kind of the idea
that you'll be sitting at your desk and
nothing will come to you anymore you
know the muses will say you know we got
to work with this guy in chicago he's
just 20 years old he's just starting out
uh you know take care of yourself jack
so i i i use that cliche that the
the muse
won't come anymore you
you you won't have it
what
an athlete can lose it a writer can lose
it you never know
but can you lose it for a while and get
it back i know the the writer's block
but is that really that the muse won't
come anymore well i look but we're
getting into technicalities here i don't
believe in writer's block okay
i can write a sentence
hemingway once said
uh when he had write his block he said
he would write this down you've done
this before
you can do it again
all you have to do is write one true
sentence
he didn't mean true factually
he meant a sentence that was
authentically
spoken and real and not trying to be a
writer and not trying to gussy it up
just saying the simplest thing you could
say
you've done this before
you can do it again all you have to do
is write one true line well
i don't have writer's block
you know why
because here's what i write
i got up this morning at seven o'clock
i don't feel like writing today
i don't have anything to write about
it looks like it's gonna rain and later
i have to go to ralph's to get a chicken
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
i don't know what i'm going to write
about but i don't care
i'm just i'm going to write well i don't
feel like writing i have nothing to
write about i feel like i have writer's
block but of course i never have
writer's block i don't know what it is a
big wooden thing inside my head
just write you don't have to have a
story you don't have to have an idea
just connect with that moment and maybe
you'll write crap but you'll write
i don't believe in writer's block i
don't believe in the muse and
inspiration and all of that stuff i
believe in the mechanics of art
i believe if you know how to hit a a
golf ball and you know how to hit shoot
a basketball and you practice it a
thousand times then even if you're not
in the mood you can pick up the damn
ball and shoot a hoop
i can pick up the damn club and
hit the ball maybe i can only hit it 10
feet because my bones are old and i'm
tired but i can do it
i don't have to have
i need to be inspired to play golf today
imagine if a professional athlete said i
only play
when when i'm inspired
you know there goes that million dollar
contract
why do people call themselves blocked
writers
i don't know i'm not a
their therapist
they're operating under an illusion
they're not very professional
yeah if i get an injury i don't go and
play that day
but if i'm not injured
i play
i don't feel like it but i play
because i got to play
according to the schedule
so i can get up and write
i've done it before
i can do it again
all i have to do is write one true line
i got up this morning at seven o'clock i
don't feel like writing today as a
matter of fact i have nothing to write
about it looks like it's gonna rain and
later i got to go to ralph's to get a
chicken
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
it's not magic
do you think people romanticize being a
blocked writer
makes them more tragic makes them maybe
get some sympathy maybe but if they
write about it
that would be good there you go see if
you're right about it you know i feel
blocked today
all right
write about it
i just think you know if you can
physically
hold the pencil or type at your keyboard
you can write something
but
what happens is when you think of your
product
and your outline
how am i going to get from point a to b
in my outline oh i where am i going to
start and what happens when the door
closes and
oh god i have writer's block
i don't worry about that
you